دعني ابدا من حيث انتهيت وهو المشفى
العسكري في مدينه عفرين والذي كان عليه
الثقل الاكبر من منظومه الاسعاف السريع
والدفاع المدني وعمليات النقل للجرحى من
جنديرس الذي هي كانت ثانيه اكثر مدينه
متضرره شمال غرب سوريا بعد الاتارب بريف
حلب وايضا هناك سيارات نقلت المصابين من
الاتاري باتجاه هذا المشفى والنقاط
المنتشره على طول الطريق ولكن المشفى اعلن
بمرحله ما عدم امكانيه على الحاله او
وصوله الى ذروه الحاله الاستيعابيه داخل
المشفى مما مضطرهم الى وضع المصابين بارقه
او بكريدورات المشفى ومنهم من تلقى
الاسعافات الاوليه بسيارتي على باب المشفى
بسياره التي كانت تقول له الى المنطقه الى
المشفى من اجل تلقي العلاج بالانتقال الى
عقربات ايضا هناك مشفى مستشفى اعلن عن
وصوله الى ذروه الحاله الاستيعابيه وايضا
مشفى باب الهوى على الحدود السوريه
التركيه
يقوم بتقديم المصابين